hallo herzlich willkommen in S Welt
heute ist ein ganz besonderer Tag für
mich denn heute wird meine kleine große
Babymaus Samira
13 ja sie ist jetzt offiziell ein
Teenager und ich sag's euch ich liebe
dieses Mädchen über alles und sie ist
mein ganzer Stolz sie und Ella und meine
Katzen aber ich komme da nicht so ganz
drauf klar dass meine Tochter schon 13
ist ich meine ihr kennt alle die Anfänge
kennt alle das Video von Samira wie sie
den Schokopudding herstellt heute ich
eine Schokopudding ma machst heute ein
Schokopudding ja und zeigst du uns wie
das
geht rühren sollen wir das gleich mal
machen ja es ist wirklich es ist der
Wahnsinn und die Zeiten als ich noch so
Motivtorten gemacht habe wie Elsa oder
die Monster Torte die schlittschuhtorte
alle möglichen bunten
Motivtorten diese Zeit scheint jetzt
gerade so bei
ihr vorbei zu sein deswegen muss eine
Teeni Torte her und ich habe gehört bzw
Samiras beste Freundin Greta und ihre
kleine Schwester Ella haben mir verraten
Samira liebt dunkelgrün und Gold
mein hat sie gesagt sie will ein
dunkelgrünes Zimmer mal schauen ob da
was draus wird jedenfalls habe ich mir
gedacht ich mache jetzt eine schöne
dunkelgrüne Torte und die eignet sich
aber auch ganz gut jetzt für die
Weihnachtszeit denn ihr könnt daraus
eine Weihnachtstorte zubereiten wenn ihr
möchtet ich würde jetzt sagen wir
starten direkt mit den Zutaten denn es
gibt jetzt erstmal einen
mandelröhrkuchen das ist ein Basisrezept
das Rezept gibt's schon auf meinem Kanal
aber ich zeig euch mal kurz die Zutaten
für den Teig verwende ich sechs Eier 300
g Zucker etwas Salz und Vanilleextrakt
jeweils 300 g Sonnenblumenöl und
Buttermilch 450 g Mehl 200 g gemahlene
Mandel etwas Zimt und ein Päckchen back
Pulver das sind drei Teelöffel zuerst
verrührt ihr jetzt die Eier mit dem
Zucker Salz und Vanilleextrakt richtig
schön weißcremig und den Ofen könnt ihr
auch gerne schon mal vorheizen auf 170°
oberunterhitze ich back das Ganze gleich
in vier backringen ihr könnt aber auch
nur zwei backringe nehmen dann ist die
Backzeit einfach etwas höher geht
natürlich beides und falls ihr die
boschgäte habt die ich auch habe oder
auch andere Geräte die Home Connect
fähig sind also WLAN besitzen könnt ihr
sie ganz gerne mit meiner App verbinden
denn dann könnt ihr einfach die
Einstellwerte aus meiner App direkt an
den Ofen senden da müsst ihr nichts mehr
einstellen es macht einfach meine App
von ganz alleine dann rührt ihr jetzt
die beiden Flüssigkeiten ein statt
Buttermilch könnt ihr auch normale Milch
verwenden ihr könnt eine Limonade nehmen
Kaffee einen Likör alles was euch
schmeckt und eben die Torte in dieser
Hinsicht gut verfeinern könnte hier
passt Buttermilch allerdings richtig gut
und wenn ihr die zwei Zutaten eingerührt
habt könnt ihr die trockenen Zutaten
verrühren miteinander und nur noch ganz
kurz einrühren oder
unterheben
man hät auch eine größere Schüssel
nehmen können hätte hätte
Fahrradkette ach was
gekert hast du das gesehen ich h einfach
die herzchüte nehmen
können jetzt könnt ihr diese rührmasse
einfüllen ich habe wie gesagt hier diese
vier Tortenringe und die Tortenringe
liegen auf den springformböden denn der
Teig ist ja relativ flüssig und könnte
Auslaufen ihr könnt aber auch die
Tortenringe einfach mit Backpapier
einschlagen und das tolle ist ich habe
hier so eine Innenskalierung an meinen
tortenringen das heißt ich sehe auch
immer ganz genau bis wohin ich das
Auffüllen muss damit eben alle vier
gleichmäßig befüllt sind d kommen sie
schon in den vorgeheizten Backofen 170°
oberhin
oberunterhitze und brauchen ungefähr 35
bis 40
Minuten die Kuchen Böden sind jetzt
gebacken und kühlen gerade noch ab ich
habe sie nämlich einfach hier bei
Raumtemperatur abkühlen lassen und habe
sie dann in den Kühlschrank gestellt
damit sie gleich beim Torte füllen
direkt eiskalt sind ihr könnt die auch
ganz gerne vorbacken abkühlen lassen und
einfrieren dann kühlt eure Torte später
einfach noch ein bisschen besser und das
ist wirklich so der beste Tipp wenn man
Torten füllen will die auch schnell fest
werden einfach die Tortenböden schneiden
einfrieren und dann habt ihr gefrorene
Böden die ihr dann schichtet und dann
wird die Buttercreme sofort fest ich
habe jetzt hier schon mal angefangen die
Buttercreme zu
muss zugeben ich nehme jetzt heute eine
fertige Buttercreme ihr könnt aber auch
eine italienische französische
amerikanische Swiss merang buttercream
von meiner von meinem Blog nehmen und
einfach ein Rezept davon verwenden hier
habe ich jetzt schon die weiche Butter
und ich weiß dass viele Buttercreme
nicht mögen aber das Geheimnis bei
Buttercreme ist zum einen dass ihr
einfach viel Butter
verwendet und zum anderen dass die
Butter aber dann auch wirklich richtig
lange verrührt wird und zwar soangee bis
s hier so wie hier schön weißcremig ist
das bedeutet bei mir in dem Fall locker
10 bis 15 Minuten mit so einem flachen
gummischaberrührer also dieser
Flachrührer flexirührer mit der
Gummilippe Schneebesen ist nicht so gut
geeignet der legt zwar schön schaumig
aber der kratz ist nicht ganz vom Rand
deswegen damit einfach schön lange
verrühren und für meinen Fall jetzt hier
gerade mit der fertigen Buttercreme muss
ich jetzt einfach nur noch diese
buttercremeemasse die jetzt hier den
Pudding einfach nur ersetzt hier jetzt
löffelweise einrühren
[Musik]
so sieht die Buttercreme jetzt perfekt
aus die stelle ich jetzt kurz zur Seite
holol die Tortenböden und noch gefrorene
Himbeeren das wird dann sozusagen die
Füllung für sameras Torte und noch
bisschen
schokohaselnusscreme ja mandelböden
schokohaselnusscreme gefrorene Himbeer
Buttercreme und die
Süßigkeiten ich glaube das wird ein
geschm
Geschmackserlebnis jetzt wird die Torte
gefüllt ihr könnt entweder ein
ganachingbard nehmen in der Größe der
Tortenböden also 20 cm oder ihr könnt
die Torte auch so füllen dass sie extrem
gut gerade wird mit einem hohen
Tortenring und so mache ich das jetzt
heute das heißt ich lege jetzt hier ein
etwas größeres ganachingbard hin ein
tortenretter geht aber auch und für
euren Nachteil ist es leider dann nur so
dass man jetzt nicht so gut sieht wie
das sich alles füllt aber für mich ist
einfach so dass ich so die Torte
schneller gekühlt und gerade bekommen
das heißt der erste Tortenboden ist da
ich habe die jetzt auch einfach mit
einer tortensäge alle durchgeschnitten
ich habe acht Tortenböden dann kommt
jetzt hier ich habe jetzt hier einfach
noch meine restlichen Zutaten etwas
Schokoladencreme dann nehme ich die
Haselnuss und Kakaocreme von
bonm unsere neue große Liebe muss ich
sagen ist einfach die Beste schokoladenh
eluscreme da kommt jetzt etwas da drauf
schön
verstreichen dann ein paar gefrorene
Himbeeren die können da so ein bisschen
zerbröseln jetzt die Süßigkeiten und
darüber kommt jetzt Buttercreme damit
ich die Torte aber perfekt gerade
bekomme nehme ich einen hohen Tortenring
der 20 cm hoch ist und damit ich später
leicht rausbekommen etwas
tortenrandfolie aber wie gesagt ihr
könnt das ganze auch ohne Tortenring
befüllen ihr müsst einfach gerade
hochstapeln schön glatt streichen und
dann klappt es natürlich auch ich zeige
euch jetzt die erste Schicht Buttercreme
noch kurz so damit ihr einmal so die
Schichten mitinander seht und dann packe
ich es aber drumrum und füll so die
gesamte
Torte mit der Cremeschicht levelt ihr
das quasi wieder aus also alles was
jetzt hier uneben ist macht ihr mit der
Cremeschicht wieder
[Musik]
eben
Butter mach jetzt auch einfach so dass
ich den Tortenboden hier direkt
bestreiche und ich muss ja auch sagen
dass die Paletten einfach die besten
allerbesten frühstücksstreichmesser sind
weil sie schön breit sind und da extrem
viel nnuercreme Frischkäse oder Butter
drauf passt und ihr damit euer Brot
perfekt glatt streichen könnt glaubt's
mir wollt nicht mit mir frühstücken doch
eigentlich schon das sieht dann immer so
perfekt glattgestrichen aus beim
Frühstück mein
[Musik]
Brot
einen Boden habe ich jetzt noch übrig
aber den Opfern wir jetzt einfach für
euch auf
okay
schade und jetzt kommt hier direkt
Buttercreme noch mal drauf erstmal eine
eine Schicht hier sind nämlich noch so
ein paar Krümelchen die will ich nicht
mit in der Buttercreme haben und dann
könnt ihr praktisch damit gleich die
Torte voll ins glatt streichen so erste
Schicht ist
bedeckt jetzt nimmt ihr die restliche
Buttercreme und ich sehe es schon kommen
ich brauch noch eine dritte
Portion dachte sagst noch mal oh
schade und jetzt Streich dir die Creme
einfach hier rein und zieht sie oben am
Rand des Tortenrings glatt
[Musik]
so sieht die Torte perfekt aus und da
kommt jetzt einfach die Folie drauf noch
ein ganashingbard und so kann sie in den
Kühlschrank bis sie komplett fest ist es
dauert jetzt würde ich mal sagen eine
Stunde ungefähr das heißt ich kann in
der Zwischenzeit noch mal Buttercreme
machen bisschen Deko aufbauen und dann
geht's mit der Torte gleich weiter die
könnt ihr aber so auch gerne am Vortag
schon zubereiten und
kalstell wow die ist
groß könnt natürlich wenn ihr nicht so
eine hohe Torte machen wollt auch eine
25er backen dann ist s etwas flacher und
größer im durchmess aber ich find so
hohe Torten einfach schön modern modern
und schön oh das istffach wird aber auch
gehen aber ich stell jetzt
dain
schwer schwer ist auch
jetzt ist die Torte schön
gekühlt und ich kann den Tortenring
erstmal
abnehmen zack
wow was eine
Torte hab ich da die Buttercreme
vergessen ah ich habe es da aus Versehen
anders rum
gemacht ich habe da erst Buttercreme
egal macht nichts kriegen wir jetzt
schön verschlossen jetzt quasi hier alle
Lücken erstmal
auffüllen jetzt schön am Rand glatt
streichen das geht am besten mit so
einer großen teigarte die könnt nämlich
im rechten Winkel hier ansetzen Zack und
wegziehen und wenn dann noch Lücken sind
kommt da die Creme noch mal drauf und
die restliche Creme werde ich gleich
einfärben aber erstmal machen wir hier
die Torte perfekt
[Musik]
glatt
perfekt die kommt in den Kühlschrank
dann kann die Buttercreme noch mal fest
werden und den Rest werde ich jetzt
schön dunkelgrün einfärben habe ich da
jetzt ja habe
ich
ich glaub habe ich schon mal am
Geburtstag meines Kindes die Torte erst
gebacken und fertig gestellt habe ich
noch nie ich habe eigentlich immer
vorher
vorbereitet schon schon Druck heute hier
es muss schon gelingen alles ne Samira
möchte denke ich mal eine grünoldene
Torte haben denn sie will auch ihr
Zimmer grün haben haben dunkelgrün und
sowohl Ella als auch ihre beste Freundin
meinten grün und gold sind ihre Farben
also werde ich die tort jetzt grün gold
gestalten ich nehme jetzt etwas
Buttercreme und ich zeige euch da jetzt
mal einen Trick Lebensmittelfarben
verstärken sich nämlich in ihrer
Intensität wenn sie erwärmt werden das
heißt wenn ihr z.B einen Teig einfärbt
da muss er nicht komplett schwarz sein
der wird einfach schwarz wenn er ein
Pack ist nicht wenn er verbrennt sondern
weil sich die Farbe eben intensiviert
aber wenn ihr ein knalliges Rot haben
wollt reicht auch da im Teig einfach nur
eine etwas blassere Farbe im Ofen
verstärkt sie sich bei Buttercreme ist
natürlich so die Buttercreme wird jetzt
nicht mehr erwärmt oder gebacken das
heißt ich nehme eine kleine Menge
Buttercreme da kommt jetzt grüne
Farbpaste rein und ich zeige euch das
auch gleich im direkten Vergleich einen
Teil werde ich dann erwärmen einen Teil
nicht nur um es euch zu zeigen diese
Menge lasse ich jetzt da die wird jetzt
kurz in der Mikrowelle einfach nur
erwärmt schaut mal sieht man hier schon
im direkten Vergleich dass sie viel
dunkler ist ich rühre sie mal kurz durch
natürlich ist jetzt leicht warm aber das
jetzt so eine kleine Menge das macht
jetzt gar nichts ich zeig euch jetzt
gerne wie es aussieht wenn ich damit
auch die Menge Buttercreme einfärb denn
jetzt sagt ihr vielleicht okay bei der
kleinen Menge macht jetzt den
Unterschied aber wie pas was passiert da
mit dem Rest das zeige ich euch jetzt
einfach guckt mal nehm kurz dieses
Schälchen mach einfach genauso viel
Buttercreme rein dann sieht man echt
ganz deutlich
dass die komplette Buttercreme einfach
eine dunklere Farbe bekommt das jetzt
die hellere Version ohne
erhitzen ihr seht es jetzt so ein helles
Grün ich müsste da jetzt echt noch viel
Lebensmittelfarbe dazu geben dass es
einfach dunkler
wird so die dunkle Version die erwärmte
[Musik]
Version die butterc noch kurz erwärmt
und kalt gestellt und jetzt sieht man
den Unterschied auch tatsächlich sehr
deutlich guckt mal hier jetzt hat auch
wieder die gleiche Konsistenz durchs
kühlen und man sieht einfach zack fehl
dunkler also kann ich jetzt die übrige
Creme schön mit der dunklen Buttercreme
einfärben und die helle die ich da habe
die stelle ich auch ganz kurz in die
Mikrowelle damit die auch dunkler wird
und ich eben ein richtig schönes
dunkelgrün hab schönes sattes
dunkelgrün
kleideng große Messbecher nehmen können
ne bisschen Buttercreme zum Kleben oh
Gott ich die schwer die schwerste
torttenplatte
ausgesucht sitzt die mit
dich oh
Gott
hab da mal so eine Torte auf einer
Marmorplatte und jetzt nimmt ihr eure
wunderschöne Buttercreme und streicht
die Torte
[Musik]
glatt
ich finde die Torte jetzt schon mega ich
also eigentlich würde ich die gern so
lassen ich bin mir nicht sicher
irgendwie finde ich es auch cool glatt
jetzt paar Kugeln drauf bisschen
Glitzersterne ist schon eine perfekte
[Musik]
Weihnachtstorte mega schön oh es ist
schöne Farbe jetzt noch ein kleiner
Trick für die Tortenplatte ihr nehmt
jetzt einen Teigschaber einen sauberen
und nehm damit hier am Rand quasi die
Unreinheiten
Weg habe ich hier meine golddek ich habe
Gold Zuckerstreusel habe Rocher und
maltesa auch noch mit goldenem
Glitzerpulver so ein bisschen ummantelt
ihr könnt aber auch goldenes
glitzerspray verwenden und die setze ich
jetzt hier einfach oben drauf so ganz
dezent
und
[Musik]
schön muss sagen die gefällt mir so
richtig gut ich nehme die jetzt mal mit
rüber nehme auch noch meine zusätzlichen
Kugeln mit aber an sich ist die Torte
jetzt fertig da kommt jetzt gleich noch
die 13 drauf oder falls ihr sie für
Weihnachten zubereitet gerne auch noch
mal Sternchen verwenden es gibt z.B
diese hübschen kleinen goldsterne wobei
ich finde die passen hier bei samera
auch noch ganz
gut aber nur ganz dezent und dann lass
wir uns die Torte mal
[Musik]
schmecken
love
[Musik]
love to
you happy
birthday
[Musik]
happythday
аде ag viel Glück zum Geburtstag viel
Glück zum Geburtstag Liebe Samir zum
Geburtstag viel Glück auf einmal jetzt
[Musik]
[Applaus]
komm